oh that's way for some people to come in
here I'm in the car and an outpoint loco
for one anyone who's hopping in on this
bad boy very late right now such a
surprise
hey Damon Nick what's going on friends
okay
there's there's enough people here right
now I
I was just on collider movie talk you
guys should go watch that episode I had
a really fun time doing it and I stayed
in Burbank because I went to go meet up
with a friend to check out their new
like movie studio spot and then I was
like okay my John wick chapter 3
screening starts in about an hour I'm
gonna go to El Pollo Loco when I was at
El Pollo Loco my girlfriend Olivia
texted me this is news and I was like
what I'm moving these sighs I was like
what the [ __ ]
Robert Pattinson's Batman this is so
weird
and I'll be honest I'm gonna be honest
yes my my first reaction my first
reaction was I don't like this this is
not good because like I think like how
most people we probably all went to
Twilight Robert Pattinson and Twilight
because that's where my mine always go
so that was his biggest movie and it
really hasn't had a big movie other than
the Twilight franchise but then thinking
about it and then like going back to
resigner DB I'm like wasn't there some
like there's freakin films he's done
though and then I was thinking about
like the movie good time that Cronenberg
flick he said a lot of really really
good he's done a lot of really good
films and he's proven himself to
actually be a great actor so as much as
I have our preconceived notions and then
I was also thinking back to when Ben
Affleck was cast as Batman and
the outrage that came with even Michael
Keaton had so much outrage I live in
Heath Ledger had all this outraged
people there's usually this like outrage
when someone's cast right it's like
walking Phoenix was cast everyone
thought that was cool but for for Batman
there there tends to be a lot of
backlash and we have a hard time
imagining who's cast to be the Batman
character I am actually gonna get I'm
not gonna hop on the train because I
feel like this type of casting will
probably lend itself to a lot of hatred
will probably lend itself to a lot of
you know like that's not my Batman or
the way people would imagine Batman to
sort of look or feel like and I feel
like most people are probably just gonna
go off of his twilight performance but
he's done a lot of work that really
shows he's a damn good gritty dramatic
actor and I feel like for anyone in this
chat right now anyone in this chat who
has seen other movies of his outside of
Twilight please go ahead and bleep
comments leave the movies that you
recommend for to check out of our pants
is worth because I feel like he's the
the backlash he's gonna suffer is gonna
be because of Twilight when you think
about it there's a lot of great actors
in Twilight who do who do not do a good
job and that franchise period so I don't
know I'm gonna I'm gonna give this a
chance I feel like I feel like he's
gonna it's Matt Reeves Matt Reeves is
very specific on who he's gonna cast
Matt Reeves is he doesn't Muse's not do
a bad job by casting so as much of a sub
like this to me is more surprising than
Chris Rock working on the next jigsaw
movie such as such a strange strange
strange casting but then when I really
reflect on you know what he did a great
job and some of those other movies
though I and that's true
people are pointing out he edits it
himself even hates Twilight it kind of
shows in his performance so again I mean
let's go through this chat let's see
what some people are thinking register
I gotta go leave in like five minutes to
uh yeah he's playing young Batman I
gotta leave a find this I'm gonna go
catch my John wick Chapter three screen
with my group
but yeah I'm chilling in an El Pollo
Loco parking lot right now okay someone
just said about like watch him hit the
gym and I really think once we see you
know that photo
think about it how these things go down
we're like what Oh
casting oh that's the way we react right
I think the right one we see the the
shirtless photo where he's so buff or
even like he's rocking a suit to need
like a Wayne Manor is something you know
what I mean
well I think a lot of us would be like
you know what I thought that this was a
bad idea but hey after seeing this image
he looks great as Batman I like like I
said my first reaction I was not for
this but then thinking about his other
body of work he might actually I think
he could actually really pull this off
and you know they've been they've been
going around looking for the right
person to cast for a long time it could
probably be him it could probably be
like you know Matt Reeves calling the
shot here I'm actually not used to
trying to read comments doing a live
stream at the same time but yeah see
everyone is here people are remembering
I'm looking down on this everyone is
everyone's remembering that he no I have
not seen the Batman versus TMNT movie
not yet though and thank you for whoever
gave me the super judges now a dollar
ninety-nine might easier to buy some
popcorn at the theaters I don't know
what are you guys hoping for in this
Batman film though what are you guys
really looking forward he is a good
actor whoa soccer master thanks so much
dude that's very kind of you I'm gonna
buy the group popcorn at home thank you
I get if you cannot see it right now I
honestly get if right now you can't see
it don't have expectation with DC you do
a pretty good job I heard about that
Batwoman trailer I'm you know for some
reason I'm just not too interested in it
hoping Bela
how [ __ ] weird would it be if they
got a person's dimmer to be like
Catwoman or something in this franchise
but I'm liking looking at the comments
here because there's such a mixed
response here from people some people
seem really happy with it and other
people seem like they're really not cool
with it remember guys remember how bad
it was when Ben Affleck was cast
everyone was upset and I remember doing
a video but Thank You Alexander that's
very sweet of you I remember of doing a
video with John being like yeah you know
what I think Ben Affleck might actually
do a good job and I think we have to
keep that in mind this is just the way
it goes directors have very specific
visions and Robert Pattinson has a much
larger body of work outside of Twilight
really got to remember that really God I
remember that Gotham by Twilight that's
a really good one right there and well I
have well I guess I have you hear about
have you guys had to leave in like three
to four minutes who do you think should
play the The Riddler
or what villain do you want to see
inside of this movie
vampire Batman gym kid okay well there's
a lot of people opting for Jim Carrey
again damn I did not expect that Nic
Cage I did hear penguins rumor I think I
think getting a good penguin would be
really cool someone who's like you know
the Oswald Cobblepot like real real mob
boss bill and not like whatever
politician wasn't Batman Returns even
though I like Batman Returns him I do
Greg should play Batman you know about
that
I mean it's been reported from variety
so I'm taking it as official usually
variety doesn't get this stuff wrong how
crazy would it be if they were like
actually he's not playing Batman he's
playing the penguin of estranged
Deathstroke who would be in a lot of
ways if they decimate soccer master your
new orbs you who are you soccer master
I'm I'm falling in love with you right
now
thank you I would be a great villain I
think I would okay I would love to see a
Hugo Strange it someone just commented
that it's hard to keep it all these
consoles are going so fast
someone just commented Hugo Strange and
and Deathstroke being in there and I
think they would be amazing villains to
have in this I really want to see
different villains here I I'm kind of
wondering if they are in some way
setting this up because they're always
gonna have an older Joker with Joaquin
Phoenix and I know they've been saying
that's its own universe it's it's own
thing outside has nothing to do with the
the Canon of the DC films but I'm kind
of wondering with having an
intentionally younger Batman if in some
way that this Batman will eventually go
toe-to-toe with Joaquin Phoenix's Joker
but Deathstroke would be a great I would
I think for the first installment as I
think it would be cool to have an Arkham
Asylum movie down the road where you do
get like a row gallery of villains Thank
You King gee soccer Matt thank you buddy
I think it'd be cool to have like sort
of it I've always thought it'd be cool
to do a Batman franchise we're
you let Batman really age like you need
an actor who's as committed as Hugh
Jackman was to the Wolverine where he
keeps or basically you know you watch
him aged into an old man Batman kind of
like what they did with old man Logan
but by the time you get to old man
Batman you could sort of take
inspiration from the Arkham Asylum comic
where he has to face his whole rogue
gallery there and I think it would be
cool to introduce Hugo Strange they're
only watch that's a Gotham season too
and I loved the elements of Hugo Strange
running Arkham Asylum and I think that
would be a very cool addition to have it
super fans must that should be the
villain they go because your first
couple villains you should definitely I
think you know Deathstroke and Payne
would be cool because Deathstroke is the
man who can match him in a martial arts
arena weapons and stuff and but he
Deathstroke kills and penguin for sort
of a criminal genius and of course you
know now you got Joker's criminal genius
DC piggo so yeah if Bruce Wayne sparkles
I riot bro don't worry he's not gonna
Sparkle it would be fun to have a little
bit of a joke all right guys what time
is it I gotta go see John wick Chapter
three in just a few minutes who should
play Robin aren't they working on a
Nightwing movie man that would be so
cool to see tonight way to go I hope
that Nightwing movie finally happens
anyway guys I do gotta get going I want
to thank everyone who contributed to
this super a chat here I sometimes
forget that the live streams lend itself
to that one on my phone like I got to
talk about this before I get into the
theater but thank you guys for tuning
and it's it's interesting to read the
wide mix response of comments so much
divided in fandoms these days but for
everyone who's really worried just wait
for that first image wait for that first
image wait for that first trailer you
know well it's not just let's try to
stop judging so heavily before we see
some real [ __ ] all right
much love for everyone thank you for
everyone who joined
I don't know how to end this but okay I
figured it out
take care